Our topic today is the dark
ages and the world of homer.
And of course you have,
uh,
as one of your reading assignments of
problem that deals precisely with that
question that asks the
subordinate questions. Uh,
was there a world,
a real world that Homer's poems refer to?
If so,
what world was it?
Was it the world of the
Mycenaean Bronze Age?
Was it the world that succeeded that
Bronze Age that we call the dark ages?
Was it,
uh,
the world in which we tradition says homer
himself lived that we think of as the
transition to the classical,
well,
first of the archaic and
into the classical period.
It's a period in which we think
about the dawn of the Polis. Uh,
that that really is the
question we are wrestling with.
And of course I'd behind
it all is the idea,
can we seek any historical information
from his Po Homer's poems at all?
It would be a terrible blow to me and
everybody else in the field if the answer
was no,
because just about everything we
have to say about this interim,
this period between the Bronze Age
and the emergence of the Polis, uh,
most of it involves inferences from our
understanding of what the Homeric poems
tell us.
Uh,
but I think we need to take a hard look
at what we can do and I thought it would
be worthwhile reading a
sentence each from the, uh,
uh,
introductory paragraphs that we provide
for you in the problem to show you the
range of opinion that is a pretty good,
pretty representative of what scholars
think or have thought on the subject.
Moses Finley says,
if then the world of Odysseus is to be
placed in time as everything we know from
the comparative study of heroic poetry
says it must be the most likely centuries
seem to be the 10th and the ninth.
That is to say what we call the dark ages.
Antony Andrews says,
it may be that the epic tradition had at
some stage used as a model for the army
before Troy.
An idealized version of some of those
bands of colonists who settled the coast
of Asia minor in post Mycenaean Times.
And if you look at the
whole story that he tells,
that really means quite soon after
the fall of the Mycenaean world,
probably maybe a century earlier
than what Findlay suggests.
And then, uh, am Snodgrass says,
I offer this as a further argument against
the existence of a historical Homeric
society.
There isn't anything to be
found is what Snodgrass says.
Ian Morris writes,
the balance of probability seems to be
in favor of a consistent basis to the
society of the poems derived from
Greece in the eighth century BC,
which would be at the end of the period
we've been talking about the transition
to the world of the Polis Homer's
own time when he lived in rose.
And finally, Barry Strauss says,
ironically, the more homer exaggerates,
the more authentic he is as a
representative of the bronze age.
So what do we do? Well, all of these
are learned and clever men. Uh,
but I don't think that
they're all equally right. Uh,
but what I should also report to you
is that I think there is a widespread
consensus among most people
who study the subject.
That doesn't mean that
consensus is correct,
but not all of these opinions
are shared by the same number,
by no means of uh, scholars.
Some of them are far out.
I would say the one that says you can't
learn anything from this is an outlier.
The notion that this is about the
Mycenaean world is an outlier and then you
get,
I would say the largest consensus is
something like Finley's consensus,
but people verging in both directions.
From that,
what you'll hear from me is essentially
that consensus point of view.
It strikes me as being better
supported than the others,
but we really have to keep an open mind
because in this prehistoric period,
which really we were still
are in such a period,
you have to be very modest about
what you think you know about it.
Almost everything is inference
and judgment and very
little is anything that you
want to call proof with those warnings.
Let me tell you sort of what, what the,
what I think most people think about this.
First of all,
uh,
if we want to know about the dark ages,
what sources do we have available to us?
And of course I've already mentioned
the poems of homer turn out to be a very
large source, uh, for what
most people look to. Secondly,
there are legends that the Greeks
told about their early history,
uh,
which come down to us in later sources
and they are available to us to use a
source as a great question is should
we use them at all? And if we do,
how carefully should we use them?
And so on.
This is a good time for me
to make a confession so that
you'll know how to judge
what I say all through the course.
Um,
beginning,
well,
I'd say prior to the late 18th century
when a German scholar began to look at
the Homeric poems specifically very,
very carefully and then really very,
very skeptically and to make all sorts
of suggestions that the poems that we
have a really not to be thought
of as the work of a single poet,
homer who had brought them both out
together but who were began to divide them
up into early and late elements,
which I thought drove the field of
classics insane for about a hundred years.
While they are folks who argued
about the unity of homer, the unity,
or not the unity of one
of the poems and so on,
but it began a critical study of the
pumps for the first time and critical
methods are applied to history
for the first time ever,
really in a night,
early 19th century and thereafter.
And,
um,
it became common to reject any ancient
story that wasn't really nailed down
very,
very firmly by some device
to take a skeptical view.
And an a very interesting
example of how things change.
If you look at people say English men
writing about ancient Greece in the late
18th century,
they tell the story of the early days
based upon the legends as though the
legends were reliable
information to some degree.
When you get to the,
uh,
say the middle of the 19th century in the
work of the great English historian of
Ancient Greece,
George Grote,
he begins his story in seven
76 with the Olympic Games.
He does tell you all
about the legends first,
but he puts them aside and says, they're
just legends. Now let's talk history.
And he doesn't begin that until
the eighth century BC. Uh,
and so there is this critical
school that says you,
I won't believe anything
unless it is proven to me.
At the other extreme,
there's me,
the most gullible historian imaginable.
My principle is this,
I believe anything written
in ancient Latin or Greek,
unless I can't now,
things that prevent me from believing
what I read are they are internally
contradictory or what
they say is impossible or
different ones contradict each
other and they can't both be
right. So in those cases, I,
the ancient evidence,
otherwise you've got to convince
me that they're not true.
Um, now you might think of
this as indeed gullible.
A colleague of a former colleague of
mine put the thing very, very well.
He spoke about,
and I like to claim this,
this approach to position a of scholarship
to which we'd call the higher naiveté
and hat.
The way this works is you start out,
you don't know anything and you're naive,
you believe everything.
Next you get a college education
and you don't believe anything.
And then you reach the level of wisdom
to hire knife tay and you know what to
believe, even though you
can't prove it. Okay. Be Worn.
I'm a practitioner of
the higher knife day.
So I think the way to deal with legends
is to regard them as different from,
uh, essentially sophisticated
historical statements,
but as possibly deriving from facts,
which have obviously been distorted
and misunderstood, misused and so on.
But it would be reckless.
It seems to me,
to just put them aside and
not ask yourself the question,
can there be something
believable at the root of this?
And just just to give you some
small defense of that approach,
I always like to ask you,
I suppose saying we didn't have
a single historical record,
no newspaper, no diaries, you know,
nothing totally reliable for what
happened in the latter part of the 18th
century in America.
Would we know anything about what
happened? Of course we would.
We would know that there was a revolution.
It was against Great Britain.
I'm sure we would know that the French
assisted in that I am certain we would
know that George Washington was the
commander of our forces in that battle.
Those are easy. There's no getting
around. We'd know those things. Then then,
then it gets to be more
interesting as we speculate.
We would know as a fact that George
Washington through a silver dollar across
the Rappahannock river, except that it's
impossible so he could dismiss that one.
We would be told that he was very honest
and told his father he chopped down a
cherry tree, which would be baloney.
But we would be told that too.
But I think we would be told also very
many true things which came down to us.
So the hard job would be to select among
these legendary things to see what fact
can be found. Then it will never be
easier or deadly certain. But that's,
that's what I'm talking about
here. Um, finally there is the,
uh,
the source that people who are skeptical,
most liked to believe because it's
tangible. I'm talking about archeology,
which is the discovery and examination
and valuation of material evidence that
is not in writing the actual
remains of places where they lived,
the implements that they
used and so on and so on.
And the beautiful thing about that is
you actually have it. It's objective.
It's an object.
It's not something that somebody imagined,
but you shouldn't derive
as much confidence from it
as a lot of archaeologists
like to because it's only a thing until
you say what it means until you put a
date on it. Until you, uh,
try to understand what it really is,
what its function was,
who brought it there,
who left it there.
All those things have to be
reasoned out from the, uh,
all the evidence, all the information
you can get. So there's a store,
an astonishing amount of speculation
involved in establishing this apparently
rigorous objective technique.
You certainly need to use it and we need
to use it as carefully. That's my point.
As carefully as we use everything else.
But it is indeed very valuable.
And studying a world before
our time, uh, always.
Now we've mentioned how
important the poems are.
So we need to take a look at the question
of what they are and how we know about
them. And so on. I mentioned
to you that, uh, these,
the Iliad,
the Odyssey when known in the Western
world continuously from the time that they
were made available,
uh,
so they will know and they
were very important in the,
in the minds of those people
who knew about it. But, um,
I also mentioned last time the
impact of [inaudible] excavations,
which turned everything around the
hypers skeptical point of view taken by
scholars in Europe in the 19th century
was eroded very sharply by the discovery
of places that really convinced pretty
much everybody soon that they were Troy
and that they were my CV.
And so the stories couldn't have been
simple inventions and that began a new
phase in the story. And again,
to repeat what I said last time,
there was certain stunning physical
resemblances between what homer said and
what we could see.
The palaces were like the
palaces that he described.
The world that they lived in was a world
in which bronze was what was used for
implements and weapons and such,
not iron and that squared with,
um,
what was found in my Sini,
what was found and the Mycenaean world,
namely bronze implements and
fundamentally not orange ones.
Sometimes there was a,
there were interesting little problems
that emerged. And one of those,
it has to do with the use
of chariots in warfare.
Well,
homer has,
Cherry has his heroes
using cherries and people.
And we know,
excuse me,
we know the chariots were used in
warfare in the bronze age around the
Mediterranean Sea.
We have hard evidence of that in
Egypt and Asia minor and in the Tigris
Euphrates valley.
So you would say,
well that's another place
where homer got it right,
except for the fact that we also know
how chariots are used in warfare.
And uh,
the closest analogy I think is distance.
Think of chariots as tanks. Uh, you know,
one famous tactic as if you, if you have
an infantry force coming forward, uh,
you send tanks in it to break up the
line of the infantry and so that you can
defeat the infantry in that way.
And apparently that is the way you use
chariots in ancient bronze age warfare.
You would send the chariot racing toward
the line of infantry men and the usual
outcome was the infantry men would panic
in the face of being charged by these
things and would break their line and
give the other side and opportunity to a
wreck havoc with their army.
Well,
what did the Homeric heroes
do with their charities?
They use them as taxi cabs,
Achilles or patrol Patroclus
or whoever is on his chariot,
does the driver in front who's driving,
he is writing down from the ships or
wherever he is from the camp to the
battlefield. He might pick up
a, uh, a missile of some kind,
a spear typically and fire
it at somebody as he goes by.
This would be a drive
by killing. And, uh, uh,
but then when he really gets to where
the action is, he hops off and gets it.
Now we're going to have some five.
And so the implication
I think is that the Ma,
the memory of chariot warfare back
in the Mycenaean days lingered was,
was captured in the poetry that goes back
the bits of the poetry that goes back
to the Mycenaean period.
But how they were used was forgotten.
And so the poets in the
subsequent years then thought,
how would I use a chariot? Never having
seen a chariot fight in a battle.
And that's the outcome. So at this, uh,
Findlay particularly makes a lot of this
as being rather indicative of how he
pictures the poems work.
There are sort of legitimate memories,
some of them going way back
to the Mycenaean period,
but which may be misremembered
in some significant detail. Uh,
and then of course there's lots of stuff
that doesn't have anything to do with
the Mycenaean period.
His view is much,
if not most of what we are told about
the Homeric world comes as he says in the
10th and the ninth centuries.
Um,
one other thing, um,
that he doesn't mention,
but I think it's worth mentioning a many,
a scholar is very reluctant to admit
that there's any Mycenae and stuff here,
whatever,
although they cannot fail to concede
that some of the physical implements that
are found at Mycenae and sites are
precisely like what homer says.
But I think you can go a
little bit beyond that.
Some scholars have pointed out that in
book two of the Elliott in the section
that we call the catalog of ships,
the poet lays out just exactly how
many warships came to Troy from Greece.
And just exactly how many came from each
town and the names of the towns that
are listed in that catalog of ships.
First of all are all legitimate in the
sense every one of them we know did exist
in the Mycenaean period and perhaps no
less significant is that there are also
towns listed there that
are Mycenaean towns,
which disappeared after the
Mycenaean period. In other words,
they couldn't just have named towns
that used to be Mycenaean but was still
around. So they, that's why they knew
them. No, sometimes it that disappeared.
The names of those towns show
up in the catalog of ships.
There's just no way to explain that
except to say that catalog of ships goes
back to the Mycenaean period.
Now,
the differences between what we find
in the Homeric poems are also very
illuminating differences between that
and what we know happened after the fall
of the Mycenaean world.
For instance,
one of the most striking things
that you find in cultures,
anthropologists and
archeologists live off.
This is how what they do with dead bodies.
Now my Sini,
it's obvious they bury them in
the ground that as most of us do,
the, uh, the graves in the
circle, the shaft graves,
and then that the beehive
tombs for the big shots.
But even outside the country side,
we find graves which have
bones of people in them.
But we know that the Greeks in,
uh,
in homer don't do that.
The Greeks and homer have,
uh, incinerate the bodies
of the dead. You remember,
um, uh, the, the, um,
the Elliot ends with the,
the actual cremation of the
bodies of the relevant people.
So that's a very significant difference.
That memory had simply died out.
And it helps us to remember to
the, uh, tombs that we
know we have seen now.
They didn't see that whoever
was writing the poems of homer,
whichever, see, uh, poets were
contributing to that over the ages.
After the Mycenaean period.
They hadn't seen those Mycenaean sites.
They were buried.
Um,
there are also differences sometimes in
the shape of weapons that we find in the
Greek world after the Mycenaean period
compared to what are described in Homer's
poems. And, uh, also, um, I'm sorry. Yeah.
Homer describes certain of these weapons
which don't fit what we find in the
ground. Um, and here's another,
a critical element in the story.
The,
we know that the Mycenaeans or at least
some small number of them could write
because we have the linear B script,
which we can read.
There is no clue that there is such a
thing as writing in the Homeric poems is
one very abstruse clue where somebody
seems to know something about it.
But fundamentally it's an illiterate
society and that is a major difference
between the world of homer
and the Mycenaean world.
Some other differences,
Homer's kings,
if you just see how they live,
what they do,
what their wives do,
how they are treated by
their fellow nobleman,
they are an irrelative sense,
very weak,
very short on power and really quite poor
compared to these Mycenaean kings that
were the results of whose work and
lives we see at places like [inaudible].
I remember I tried to emphasize how rich
you would have to be to undertake the
building of the temple to undertake the
construction of one of those beehive
tombs.
You had to be a very confident because
it was going to take a long time,
fantastic amount of labor,
a tremendous amount of money to do that.
There is no evidence in homer that anybody
had that kind of wealth or that kind
of power.
What do the,
what do the Queens in homer
do in their spare time?
Or maybe it's not their spare time.
Maybe it's their regular time. Well,
one of the things that they do,
in fact, when you, when, when, uh,
the Homeric heroes referb to their wives,
they're there.
There were really only two places
that they seem to be associated with.
One is the bedroom and
the other is the loom.
What these ladies are
doing is weaving cloth.
Now that's not what Queens do.
I'm sure the Mycenaean Queen's
didn't do that, but it's very,
very interesting that that is
where the Homeric queens do that.
Well,
how are we to explain the discrepancies
that are so great between these worlds?
And the answer that almost everybody now
accepts without argument is that these
poems were,
uh,
created orally and passed on orally
that they were not written down.
And so that what we have in the poems
of homer reflects centuries of bards
passing on bits of the poem of the
poem and various versions being always
creative.
I mean,
any barred if by analogy we know
about bards in the modern world,
we have some evidence on that.
Milman parry was a,
he's a Harvard scholar back in the 20s,
went to Yugoslavia to live in
the mountains in the backwoods.
And he lived with people who were still
had these bards around who created sort
of epic narratives of considerable length,
nothing resembling Homeric length,
I must say. Nothing that long,
but long enough in which they would tell
the same stories in verse and music.
Uh, and you could recognize the
story as you went from bar to bar,
but every bard added and subtracted
things to suit his own talents.
That's the idea of the game.
And then Perry demonstrated by careful
scholarship of the Homeric poems that
that is the way the Homeric poems were.
In fact,
I want to use the word stitched together
because in the ancient Greek world,
the people who sang, recited,
created, uh, the poems of Ho, uh,
of the, of the Homeric epics
were called wraps sodas.
And that means stitchers of songs.
So what you have to
imagine is sometime back,
I would argue in the
Mycenaean Mycenaean period,
somebody began making
up one of these songs,
telling the story of Greeks
going to attack the city of Troy.
And that for centuries thereafter,
different wraps odes repeated that.
But elucidated that,
illuminated, that extended it, changed it,
try to improve it.
And uh,
sometimes they added stuff they
were alive in the 10th century.
Some of them are alive in the ninth,
and certainly some of them are alive
from the time of homer in the eighth.
So that,
that what we have before
us is that kind of product.
And that will explain both the
similarities and the differences.
And that is what underlies
our interpretation of how
the poems got to be what
they were.
So what world,
what does this world like that
emerges from the world of homer.
Even we don't have to make
up our minds in advanced,
whether it was a real world
or a completely fantastic one,
but at least let's see if we can
describe what world it looks like.
And I'm going to focus my attention on
the what you might call the political
side of that society as it
reveals itself in the poems
we hear about key individuals.
Uh,
and I've used last time I mentioned
to you two words I think I did,
but I'll mention that again this time
the,
the head of the expedition
to Troy Agamemnon,
that sort of general and mo of that
expedition is called one knocks.
When you dropped the WWE as
a Greek later dialects did,
it becomes anoxic in later Greek.
He is so far as I know,
and I think I'm not forgetting I,
he's the only human being
referred to in the poems.
In that way.
There are however many of an individual
in the palm who is referred to is a
boss, allows the plural, is bossy lace,
which is normally and
regularly translated as king.
And that's, that's right. For instance,
in historical times when
the Greeks referred to the
Great King of Persia who was
a real king and a powerful figure
figure king in every sense, uh,
the word they used for him was bossy less.
But we quickly see that the people
referred to as Bacillus in homer,
uh,
are not like the great king of Persia.
They are a much lesser figures.
I'll come back to that in just a moment.
The Mycenaean kings we know thanks to
the linear B tablets were referred to the
singular once again is one ox
and the plural is one act tests.
But in homer the term is reserved for
Agamemnon or for Gods but not for any
other human being.
And that raises the question,
why is Agamemnon one us?
And that I think we have to understand
as being big because of his function in
the situation. Namely,
there is a multi city,
uh, invasion of Troy being carried
on by these Mycenaean Greeks.
Agamemnon has been chosen as the general
list demo and that is what gives him
temporarily the title of one
ox. I would, I would imagine,
I'm very confident that
after the war of Troy,
if Agamemnon had been allowed by his
wife to live for more than a few minutes
after he set foot at home,
he would no longer be called one ox,
but would be called boss allows like
the other rulers of their local towns.
Uh,
your mirror,
you remember I suggested
that in the linear B tablets,
when there's a reference
to a bus, Laos, uh,
he's clearly well below the one ox and
some scholars suggest in a persuasive
way. I think that these Busta Laos
may have been village chieftains,
but that's as high as they got.
But it's very interesting that
when you get to historical grease,
as we shall see,
there are no one knock tastes,
but there are, at least according
to tradition, bossy lays.
But there's no, no bustle. Laos has
anything like the clout that the uh,
uh,
mycenaen kings did.
And of course we don't hear
of any of them who have the,
even the temporary special power
that Agamemnon has. Nobody,
no human being is referred to as one
ox in the period of historical Greece.
And of course the kings
when we see them in homer,
do not have a bureaucracy,
do not have scribes.
How could there be scribes?
They didn't know how to write.
There are no inventories.
These are not rich guys with fantastic
quantities of stuff that has to be
cataloged and inventoried.
The kings by our standards for
kings are really very poor.
What do they do in their spare
time or in their time in general?
They themselves engage in agriculture.
I don't mean they dig in the ground
but they supervise it but they,
they think about it.
They are like uh,
people who are in charge of a
plantation there own plantation. I mean,
so that's one of their activity.
You cannot imagine the great
kings of my Sini doing that.
They would have had all kinds of
subordinate officials taken care of that.
The another thing that these kings
are seeing to do, which is in a way,
even at a lower level,
is to be herdsman. Again,
not themselves out there
with the goats and the sheep,
but refer to as having these herds
and having to cope with them.
Another very popular,
I would say the most popular activity
among the king's popular with the Kings
was piracy.
That's what they brag about.
Kelly's my God bought a king.
He is, he sacked 24 cities.
Why do you Saca City to
steal what they have and of,
well, there are all kinds of wonderful
examples. Uh, people, uh, in the,
in the Iliad, the Odyssey,
some stranger comes,
this is in the Odyssey and the,
they ask him a sir,
are, are you a pirate?
And he says, no, no,
I'm not a pirate. Just like they asked
him. Um, I mean, you come from Chicago,
it's a, that's he, he wasn't
insulting. He didn't, I don't know.
I'm not a pirate, but am I
could have been. Of course
we understand that. But, um,
and then, but later on in the story
that, uh, hotels in the Odyssey,
Odysseus himself is such a newcomer. He
comes, he's taken to the beautiful city,
uh, on the island is
scarier if ea Hsa and, uh,
treated with great respect as you're
supposed to be in the Mycenaean world.
But after dinner, they, uh,
they do what they do to amuse themselves.
They have athletic contests and they
ask, oh, just use to participate.
And he says, no, no, I'm too miserable
and wretched. And the guy says, oh yeah,
you must be some kind of a merchant.
And, uh, with issues is,
that was a black remark.
And, uh, those are fighting
words. You can't call,
we know just uses himself as a, a
laussane. You don't call him a merchant.
Pirate Short merchant know.
Um,
another thing that is interesting is that
when you look at the burials of Greeks
in the post Mycenaean
period and the dark ages,
there's nothing resembling those grand
tombs and the wealth that's buried in
them for the dead.
You find that the tunes of nobleman are
very much the same one as the other.
You're struck by the equality from
the standpoint of riches of the dead.
Uh, nobility. No,
no great distinction and
no great riches either.
You're dealing with a poor world and
a world that doesn't have this kind of
outstanding monarchy.
So,
uh,
one of the things I think we learned
is that the Homeric world of the Kings,
the role of the Kings, the wealth of
the kingdom, the power of the Kings,
the place of the kings is not
taken from the Mycenaean period.
If it's describing anything that's real,
it's describing very clearly
a post Mycenaean world, uh,
in those dark ages that we
have been talking about.
But another thing that crops
up is that in the Iliad,
the Odyssey,
you get a very clear picture really of
what is the political structure of each
society.
And by the way,
you must keep in mind a very important
difference between the Iliad and the
Odyssey.
The Iliad takes place at Troy.
None of these noblemen,
none of these kings,
none of these heroes is back
home in his own town ruling it.
He is at war and he is
serving under a commander.
And so the behavior of these people
towards one another is not precisely like
what it would be and here you see in the
Odyssey is what it would likely be and
the place where you see it is as back
in Ithica when a is there or when we're
taking to see what's going on.
I think that's a very
important distinction to make.
But even when they were Troy and in this
other sort of non a typical situation,
we still see the same institutions working
the same relationships being present
as a would be present at home. Although
you have to watch out for the difference.
What do I mean?
How are decisions made?
Does the king simply say
do it and it gets done?
Nothing like that.
The king has got important powers.
Agamemnon has the chief
out there in the Iliad.
He can call a meeting of the assembly,
but it turns out he's
not the only one of the,
I should say if the council
will come to that in a minute,
but he's not the only one who can.
Any nobleman who wants to can say,
we ought to have a counseling and then
the council will come together and do
whatever business they wish
to do. The council, however,
is limited to nobleman
to these Boston lace.
Ordinary soldiers do not attend.
And that's one of the things I
think we must grasp immediately.
The key line in the society of the Dark
Ages appears to be certainly not between
monarchy and everybody else,
but between nobility and commoners.
That's the really
important serious line up.
Certainly politically and
in other ways as well.
There is however,
a in homer and assembly
that consists of the men.
In the case of Troy,
of course the fighting men who were
there but who are not bossy delays,
but also in the,
in the home at home,
the men of fighting age and condition,
they are the only ones
who matter of course,
as in all of the rest of Greek history,
women are excluded from the political
realm. Uh, and of course, uh,
well I'll just leave it at that.
Uh, but so too are the, uh,
uh, there's a, there's
obviously an age limit.
You have to be of an age
to be a fighting man.
It's not necessarily defined for us.
It depends on the could have been 18,
could have been 20 in a, in Athens
in classical times. It was 20.
Um, well that, let, let,
let me just remind you of some events
that show you how these things work.
Remember the Elliot starts because of a
quarrel and the quarrel emerges from the
fact that the Greek Sir Bisley
being killed by a terrible
plague that has struck
them. Uh, they said, we've got
to find out what's happening,
why they always assumed that if
something like that happened,
it was some God or gods
who was angry with them.
So they get a seer who goes and says,
is persuaded to try to
find out what's happening.
And he finally does ascertain that
Apollo is angry with the Greeks because
Agamemnon took a maiden
from her father and that,
uh, father was a priest
of Apollo. And so, uh,
when this is ascertained,
the Achilles, the biggest,
bravest, strongest,
fastest, a hero, uh, on the,
on the Greek side intervenes
and says, well, look,
why don't you give back the girl and
then Apollo will stop killing us and
everything would be okay.
Ag I'm in him,
gets furious with Achilles and he says,
no,
I'm not giving back my girl. I'm the
boss here. See as Edward G. Robinson,
he used to say,
and um,
how many of you ever heard of Edward G.
Robinson? Just raise your hand, please.
Good. Put me in my place and it
gets worse every year for me. Um,
and um,
Achilles then speaks up and really let
some have it chosen that tells him what a
Bozo is. Uh, and
you know,
there's very important thing is how
can you do that if this is the king?
And the answer is you can do
that because you're both kings.
There is nothing out of line in the sense
of violating some kind of a real rule
of the society.
But it's not typical.
And especially since Agamemnon
has this position as the boss,
the most kingly of the kings, that's the
word that homer uses of him. Bossy loop,
top toss, the most kingly. And
that's because of his position.
So Achilles is not doing anything
sort of illegal or unconstitutional,
but he's doing something that's really
out of line from a normal point of view.
And finally, Agamemnon says, no,
I'm not going to give back my girl,
but tell you what, uh, I'll finally,
I will give back my girl if I am given
the girl you took from a different Trojan
and that'll be fine. I'll have
your girl and you won't have any.
So now Achilles really blows its top.
And uh,
from the quarrel, I'm
finally when he says, okay,
if that's what you're going to do to me,
I'm taking my armor and I'm going home.
And off he goes and he soaks in
his tent for the next nine books.
And uh, this turns out to be a
serious problem for them. So that,
but that what you learn from that
is that the way decisions are made,
important decisions are made even in this
army is by discussion among the bossy
lace among the nobleman. And, uh,
you will try to reach a
consensus about these things.
And in an extreme odd situation like this,
it would have to be that they would
have to do what the commander says,
but it would, and probably
back home. That would be the,
the implication that if you can't work
things out among them with consensus,
probably the king has some,
some weight.
But what we have to remember is you
can't give orders to anybody typically,
although Agamemnon can get away
with it on this expedition. Well,
that's one story and other stories that
we're told is that soon afterwards,
also in that same place in the Elliot,
a dream comes to Agamemnon, cause
you know, this is their 10th year.
They've been trying to take this
city for nine years. It's, uh,
it's almost as bad as
Iraq. Um, and people are,
the soldiers are tired of all of this.
If we can't take the city, we, um,
we ought to go home.
And there's a lot of,
is a spirit that says we
ought to go home. And so, uh,
a dream comes to a Agamemnon.
The God says to him,
here's what you need to do.
You need to try the spirit
of your men and two in,
in that way too in spirit them
to carry on until victory.
So what you should do is to get up and
speak to your soldiers and say that
you're never going to take, uh, Troy.
You might as well pack up and go home
and then they'll say, no king, no,
we refuse to do that.
We insist on staying,
we're going to re re up and do another
term and we're going to take the city.
So agrimonia says, great, I'll do that.
And he calls the troops again the battle
and he makes his little speech and then
I can, I wish I could reproduce the
home or I didn't take it along with me.
But the essence of it is in a
great roar and rumble emerge.
There's the troops turned and began racing
back to the ships to get the hell out
of there.
Just to carry on some of the highlights
of that story that tell us a little bit,
a lot really about the society.
So as they're roaring back,
suddenly Odysseus to slice the cleverest,
the smartest of all of the Greeks.
He goes racing among the
troops who are heading back in.
He grabs one and homer says,
when he came to a gentleman,
a boss, the lace who say,
sir, you are making a mistake.
You don't understand the game
that Agamemnon is playing.
And he explains it to them.
And the guy said, okay,
when he comes to one of the common
sort, he says, you bloody imbecile.
Get the hell back to where you belong.
That's a rough translation. And,
uh,
everybody finally grabs enough of
them and the thing turns around,
everybody goes back and sits down and,
uh,
up steps,
one man
suit,
uh,
homework describes him as the
ugliest man in the entire army.
So you get a clue as to what we're
supposed to think about him. And uh, he,
he makes his speech,
which denounces all of the Basa
Lace Agamemnon ahead of any of them.
And he says,
we ordinary soldiers have had enough and
we would like to go home and up steps
Odysseus and blessed him with his septor,
smashes him across the back,
leaving a welt that could
be seen by the entire army.
And tears came to the eyes of this guy.
Are we supposed to feel sorry for
him? Well, the next lines in Homer's,
say one soldier popped up and said,
of all the great things Odysseus has
done for us here, that was the greatest
to shut up big mouth idiot.
Like their societies.
Well, what's their Saudis had
done that was wrong. Of course,
uh,
the poet and a and the dishes
didn't like his policy suggestion,
but what he really had them,
he had no right to speak at all.
The only people who could speak in the
council or in an assembly where the
nobleman,
the boss delays.
So he had crossed the line
in as an ordinary soldier.
And to rise and to say anything
was a violation of the culture.
And that's one of the places where you
see whether it's sharp line exists,
they just take orders.
But the gentlemen don't just take orders,
they can argue and sometimes
can win the argument.
So what you see in this very brief and
inadequate account that I've given you is
that we really,
in spite of the fact that we have
bossy lace and even in this case,
uh, uh, [inaudible],
we really don't have a
proper monocryl tradition.
When we think of monarchs single rulers,
we think of Hama, Robby and we
think of, uh, the kings of Persia.
And we think of Louis the 14th.
We do not think of what we have here,
which is a bunch of noblemen
who are essentially equal.
And the differences between them don't
come from birth or rank as between them,
but from wealth and power
that they happen to possess.
It is rather not a royal society,
but an heiress to crack society. I
think that's the, the main message.
And it is the matrix
of all future political
ideas and arguments in the
Greek world that comes after
this time. I think, yeah,
you need to understand that.
Um,
what the Greeks in the historical period,
once we start having written
records by the Greeks themselves,
the thing that is the,
this is the standard position.
What does this thing on the computer,
when you fall back to a position,
what do you call that position?
Huh?
Say it again. No, no, no fallback.
What does it default? That's right. Good.
The default position in a Greek
political theory is aristocracy.
That is done normal thing.
Uh,
a good, uh, I've, yes,
a very good example of that is what
I've been telling you that that's really
what happens. And here's another thing.
If you go to the end of the Greek a story,
uh,
when you think about political theory,
there's Plato and when he lays
out the ideal society in his view,
in the republic,
we find there are multiple rulers.
And these of course turned out to be the,
uh, the windows of the jeopardy contest.
Uh,
playoffs.
But it doesn't matter is never one cane.
It's always a group of people that the
best government and they will be the best
in his case, the defined by chiefly by
their intelligence. But other things too.
Uh, well anyway, in this case
in Greek political thinking,
the aristocracy of birth
is the default position.
Anybody who wants to argue for a
different kind of political arrangement,
we'll have to make the case
uphill against all tradition.
I hope that you'll have that in the back
of your head when we get to the story
of Athens and the invention of democracy
cause it was off the wall from the
perspective of Greek tradition and
of course anybody from time to time,
they were individuals who thought
that Monica might be a fine thing.
They pop,
ran against something that was even much,
much more,
uh, regarding with much more hostility
by the Greeks when they're through,
you know,
when they've reached their peak.
Their notion of monarchy is
something fit for barbarians.
But not for Greeks.
A free man may not live under a monarchy.
And the roots of that I think, uh,
are visible in home brand and passing.
I just want to say that homer,
of course,
is the basic text,
the basic document for all Greek thinking
in every area that you can imagine
throughout the rest of the Greek history.
Over time, it becomes not the only one,
but it never ceases to be the best known,
the most influential,
the most powerful. Uh, if it
were a religious document,
primarily we would speak of it
as the Greek Bible, but, uh,
it isn't nonetheless, well, some examples
later on in history, uh, somebody,
there's a quarrel between Athens and
mega as to who controls the island of
Salamis.
They decide to call in an arbitrator.
So they call in the Spartans and the
Spartans, Zay, okay, we'll decide.
And they decide that it
belongs to athletes. Why? Well,
if you look at the catalog of ships in
Homer's Iliad than the island of Sal
Amiss had his ships lined up next
to the island of Athens ballgame.
It's just you have to
realize how potent this is.
Well,
let me turn to another aspect
of the story of homer end,
how the poems play into a Greek society.
I want to talk to you about the ethics
and values that emerge from the reading
of the Iliad,
the Odyssey.
I mentioned religion and so we
should take a look first at the gods.
We are talking, first of
all, I remember about a uh,
multimedia t society.
Polytheism is what we're talking about.
That is true of all of human societies
that we know anything about down to the
earliest possible exception, I suppose.
Well, it depends on what you think.
His earliest, you could say the Hebrews
are the earliest, pure and simple,
but depending on how you
date biblical things,
there's an outside chance that an
Egyptian Pharaoh in the 16th century BC,
I think, uh, might have claimed
to have some such state.
But otherwise there is no such thing.
So this is a policy is stick society
with heroic characteristics that is this
kind of arrows to cratic outfit,
aristocracy of birth,
which is legitimized by heroic
behavior on the battlefield.
Now,
one of the things the Greeks believed as
we discover from a poem written by one
of their major poets is
something that so far as I know,
unique to the Greeks,
they claimed that they were
of the same race as the gods.
And I really don't know of
anybody else who made that claim.
Um,
and so they,
you will hear Homeric characters
referred to by epithets. Homer,
part of the technique of passing on oral
poetry is by having epithets attached
to the rulers to help with the meter.
Some hero will be called [inaudible],
meaning godly God like the old
Trefis reared as a God east.
So theos equal unto a God.
And there are others as well.
Now mind you,
notice these are not people refer
to as God fearing or lovers of God.
No,
they are just about equal to the
gods according to these terms.
Now that on the one hand is this
extraordinary claim that the Greeks make.
They did make amazingly powerful claims
for human beings as opposed to divinity
compared to any society that I know.
Anything about.
Part of the arrogance that is
characteristic of the ancient Greeks,
but at the same time and right away at
the beginning with getting to such a very
Greek thing at Greek characteristic
at the same time that he has this
great thing almost like a God.
He is also not a god in the
most crucial way possible.
Gods do not die.
Men Die.
The mortality of the human being is
a reality and it's of the greatest
significance and importance.
And of course men are not as
strong and as powerful as the gods.
And indeed as we shall see,
well the tragic view of life,
which the Greeks invent and
which characterizes their
culture is they're right
at the beginning in the
Iliad and the Odyssey,
it says that at the same time as man is
a remarkable marvel as creature capable
of all sorts of amazing things,
even on being almost like the gods.
He is nonetheless mortal and dies and
he doesn't have the power that the gods
do. And what do you do about that? Well,
it's interesting I think to compare the
Greek way of dealing with this human
problem that we all have
the problem of death.
How do we deal with the
fact that we will die? Well,
there's what I like to call the eastern
solution that you find in many an
eastern religion and philosophy that
says that man is in fact nothing.
He is dust,
he is dung.
Depending on which story you listened to.
So of course you're going to die.
Who Cares?
Why should you care?
You are nothing to begin with.
You'll be nothing when you're finished.
Relax.
Then there is what I would characterize
it as the Christian solution.
You're worried about dying.
You need not die.
If you are a good Christian and you do
all the things that you need to do to be
a good Christian,
you will not die.
You will have personal immortality.
So that's how you get around that problem.
No need to worry if you're
doing things right. Well,
somehow Christians continued to worry and
we have millennia of them killing each
other about how you're supposed to
worry about these things. But, but, uh,
but on, if you can accept the
purity of the statement I just made,
it's at the root of the thing.
You have a solution.
But the Greek tragic view does
not take either of these routes,
which I regard as a relatively easy escape
from the problem compared to the way
the Greeks got stuck.
Man is great and they keep
saying so he is important,
he is capable of great things.
He is of the same race as the gods.
And at the same time is life is short
and death is final and death is bad.
I ought to say a word about death in order
to comprehend what the Greeks thought.
You know, different people's have
had different ideas about them.
Sometimes the notion is,
is it's just terrible for everybody
with actually pain and suffering.
And others have a notion of a wonderful
kind of a heaven in which marvelous
things happen to you. Sometimes
spiritual, sometimes physical,
depending on the religion.
Uh,
but for the Greeks,
as I think for a quite a few
other people in the ancient world,
death was nothing
in the board sense of the word.
You just went somewhere
and there was nothing,
there was darkness,
there was nothing at all.
Some few people who had sinned terribly
and earned the wrath of the gods would
indeed be tortured in some
special and typically Greek.
Interesting way. Uh,
you remember a Tantalus,
he had done a terrible thing and there
he stood forever with his feet in the
water below and above him,
a tree with grapes hanging
down and dying of thirst.
And every time he went down to try this
sip some of the water, the water receded.
And anytime he reached up for the grapes,
the grapes were pulled back.
That is a Greek idea of hell.
Well,
you got to keep trying
and you always lose. So,
uh, but that's, that's the picture and
the other, you have to realize that
death is a bad thing in the
Elliott. I'm sorry, the Odyssey.
Oh,
just use has reason to go down to hades.
And while he's down there,
he comes upon Achilles who
has died and he says, well,
it's good to see you achilles.
Say you look fine.
You must really be doing okay down here.
I know that you are a judge
down here and much respected.
So it looks like you have beaten the
rat and Achilles says, oh, dishes.
Don't say a word to me
about the virtues of death.
Better to be a surf,
the lowest surf on the earth
than to be a king and hades.
Yeah,
that's as bad as it can possibly be.
The Great Achilles respected still in
the afterworld would immediately turn it
in to be a complete nobody on earth.
So,
so it's very important they
faced without any real retreat,
the reality and the uh,
the negative character of death,
even as they refuse to reject the
significance of life or of mankind.
That is what I mean when I speak of the
tragic view and it's very important.
Now it seems to me we can eliminate
that a little bit by comparing it with
various modern approaches to
the same sorts of problems.
We gotten rid of those problems
yet in spite of modern medicine
there we lived still,
I think in what might be called
the age of the enlightenment.
That is the dominant sort of
paradigm of what life is all about,
at least in the Western world.
And a good deal more of it where the West
has had an influence at the core of it
is a belief in progress.
Something that was essentially
not present among the Greeks
progress in the eyes of the
philosophers of the 18th century.
Though they would have been very angry
to hear me say this was something like
the equivalent of Christian
hope for immortality.
The hope of the Voltaires of this world
was that they could make the world
better constantly by their efforts.
And this would be rewarded
in a kind of the way,
because progress in the future after
they were gone would redound to their
credit for having brought it about me.
And that in some sense they would
live on in this society, which had,
they had improved and made a better thing.
Another aspect that is very
important in this, uh, sort of, uh,
enlightenment approach is individualism.
That the core of everything is
the single individual person.
As we shall see, this is very
different from the Greeks. Now,
the Greeks were very much concerned with
individualism and this is especially
true of the, uh, Democrats in Athens.
But even they,
even they,
even their most potent spokesman and
leader placed the goals and achievements
and everything else of an
individual behind something
that they thought was more
important,
which was to community at large,
which in historical times was us.
Well,
that's not the way it is
with the modern world.
And that's not the way it
comes out of the enlightenment.
The individual is the ultimate,
uh, the enlightenment.
If you go back to its roots
in the 17th century with the,
with the likes of Hobbes and Locke,
uh,
what is the ultimate place you go to?
It is the rights of individuals.
You may not stamp out the
rights of individuals.
They are inherent in everything.
Either you believe,
as our founding fathers said that
they were, we were in doubt, uh,
bought with them by our creator.
They didn't say God because of
course the enlightenment thinkers,
we're not so sure they believed in God,
but they still seem to
believe in something they
wanted to call a creator. Um,
so or if you didn't believe in God,
this was just a natural right nature
gave each individual the right to life,
liberty property,
and nobody could take
these away legitimately.
Well,
the Greeks had no concept of natural
rights or of rights that human beings were
given by the gods.
That is a very important difference.
That was you had to act in such a way
as to make life possible and decent.
And for the Greeks, that always meant
being part of a decent community,
the polls, but the modern world to get
back to that, to this enlightenment world,
individualism and a key
aspect to that as hedonism.
That is to say it is legitimate
and proper to search for pleasure,
for each individual to attempt
to please himself however he can.
And it turns out that there,
if you could take it to our own day,
there are no limits, pretty much
to what he can do to gain pleasure.
I would argue that there is a direct
line from the enlightenment philosophy to
nihilism.
That is to say a philosophy that says
there are no limits to what human beings
may do.
What turns out to be the practical fact
is that he who has the power and the
will to do what he wants,
we'll be able to do so.
And he who has not will be
forced to suffer whatever
the powerful impose on him.
And this is seen by the original
nihilist as a good thing.
Uh, what's his name? Uh, nature
of course said some of us are,
are better than others.
Some of us are super men and it's quite
wrong and wicked for us to be treated as
though we were ordinary fellows and
therefore do not tie us down with these
ridiculous codes of ethics and morals
and other things which are simply the
weapons by which the week hold down the
strong. This was an interesting idea,
but it wasn't noon. There's a Greek in
the fifth century. He says the same thing.
Um,
there is no definition of
goodness for this modern approach.
No definition of happiness.
Each individual decides sore himself.
What is good,
what has happened?
What it really does does is to evade
the question that I'm talking about.
Is this all okay?
If we're all going to die,
then does it really mean that we should
just do the best we can at anybody's
expense while we're alive?
Is that a satisfactory outcome?
Will we indeed be happier, better
off while we're alive? If we do that,
the Greeks would have
that is stupid and absurd.
If you think for 10 seconds,
you realize that's no good.
Now,
the Greeks on the other
hand had a powerful belief
in the dominance of chance.
They accepted what I again,
is a very modern idea now that in fact,
there is no divine force or divine forces
who oversee what happens to mankind on
earth.
But rather things happen simply
in a random way according
to no particular rule.
Uh,
and that's the way it is.
It is not virtue or merit that
determine the quality of your life.
It is chance. And, uh,
there were several places in the
Iliad and the odyssey that, um,
emphasize that point
well that leaves the Greeks with this,
something like this question in the light
of human mortality to disinterest of
the Gods,
the chances of life,
what can man do to achieve happiness
and immortality because he still doesn't
feel happy about his mortality.
Though he accepts that this is a problem.
It's something that he
still hankers after.
It's inevitable that people should and
part of the answer is very Homeric.
It is the heroic ethic at a certain place.
I think a couple of places in the Elliot,
uh,
Achilles tells us,
ask why,
why did you come here
to uh, to uh, fight? Uh,
Troy we are told,
we know the,
the legend says Achilles was told before
he came that if he did not go to Troy
and fight in that war,
he, because his, uh,
his mother was a goddess,
he had partial divinity in him.
He, uh, would be immortal.
He would never die.
But on the other hand,
he would not be great and famous.
His memory would not be carried
forward into the future.
If he went to Troy,
he would die.
But his memory as the greatest of
the Akins would be immortal forever.
Well, you know, the choice he took and
you know that it turned out to be right.
We still know about Achilles don't
mean, and when, when we were all gone,
people will know about Achilles.
So we should take the Greeks
very seriously on that score.
Well anyway, sometimes
he's asked, uh, what?
What made you come here in spite
of that? And his answer was, well,
when my father sent me here, he told me
a number of things that I'm supposed to.
But the most important of
these was the Greek words.
I ain our risk.
Stay away always be the best.
The best doesn't mean morally the
best in anything. Like our sense,
it means the greatest,
the strongest, the ablest,
the most admired. That is
what you want to be. Well,
you can only do that if
you are in a contest.
You can only be the best
if somebody is not as good.
And the Greek word for that kind
of a contest is a Goan AGLN.
And so it's fair to
think about the Greeks.
I think it's very necessary to think
about the Greeks as having a particular at
Gono society,
a society filled with competition
in which if not everybody,
lots and lots of people are constantly
striving to be the very best,
whatever the definition of best
is in the context that's relevant.
Now,
I guess I'm out of time,
so I'll pick up the story next time it
with the story about this heroic ethic
and the impact that it
has improved society.